how much responsibility do you feel you
have particularly guys the alt-right who
as you say
some of them have enjoyed your work and
so i'm not one of i'm not one of you
guys i'm not with you guys they haven't
enjoyed my work
i've definitely read bits on the
internet read more we are
we've totally flipped this culture
upside down great example of this
would be in comic books you might
imagine i'm not a huge comic book fan
but i remember when the news headline
came out that
marvel comic books i guess it was hired
tom heezy coates
the race-hustling extraordinarily
overrated writer who he's a darling of
white liberals
who award him all sorts of prestigious
awards and
give him lots of money to talk about how
terrible america is and how
how black bodies to use his phrase are
horribly oppressed
when he uses that phrase black bodies i
always wonder i said you don't think
black people have souls why do you keep
using that strange phrase black bodies
so they hired him to write the captain
america comic i said okay here we go
here we can't wait for this one to come
out well it's out
and i guess there's some villain in
captain america
called red skull and he's a really bad
guy you know
and uh in tonight's version the
red skull is jordan peterson
jordan peterson a mild-mannered
canadian professor and psychologist
whose most
outrageous statements are telling kids
to make their bed
and pursue truth and stand up straight
you know really kind of basic stuff if
you want to have a good flourishing life
he is now the villain and it's pretty
pretty clear you know
they they reference jordan's books and
the comics now they reference various
things that he said
we now in this country are being told
that truth is falsehood and right is
wrong
and good is bad that is that is not
simply a matter of free speech versus
censorship
or the public sector in the private
sector
that is a matter of one set of standards
the radical new standards competing with
the traditional standards in this
country that's really what the battle is
that is i should mention the topic of my
upcoming book speechless
the timing couldn't be better on the one
hand i'm
pleased that the book i have coming out
is about this very topic because it's
it's timely
on the other hand i'm utterly dismayed
because this is all happening
really really quickly and we're now
being told that if you want to clean
your room
and make your bed and stand up straight
and pursue truth that you're an evil
rotten nazi we're being told
this not by big government we're being
told this by the culture by comic books
by woke corporations bad
bad stuff we need to push back and it is
just too weak folks to say well but we
can't exercise any political power
because if we exercise political power
that'll make us no different than the
left
no it'll make us very different than the
left because we will be opposing
their standards we will be we will be
engaging in politics
as all successful political movements
have for all of human history everywhere
on earth
and i think some conservatives don't
have the courage to be successful they
don't want to they don't want to defend
the new standards because really they're
just liberals like asa hutchinson in
in arkansas really when it comes down to
it they're technocratic progressive
liberals who want to go a little bit
slower
well i don't think we should we have
time to do that
donald trump said he doesn't have time
for political correctness we don't have
time
to wait on that kind of stuff this is
happening
right now if you enjoyed that video be
sure to hit the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content out there
[Music]
[Music]